Hey. Yeah, this is Patrick. I'm only allowed 14. I'll come in.
You and live all your podcasts. I don't know if you guys saw it, but there was,
I finally saw a, that show. Saturday night live, finally getting good.
They finally hired a kid who knows what he's talking about. Shane Gillis.
That's a funny kid right there. Yeah.
I'm going to watch the show it because the kid shake Gill is a funny kid.
He know he's saying things that people really need to. Yeah. I beat a kid,
obviously works over at the firehouse.
Shane killers is going to see a firefight and get some skit work. Yeah.
It gets picked and some skip work I did. And then it's nice.
It's nice to see the kids coming out of the woodwork. Um, you know,
supporting him who just, you know, who want their names to go viral in articles?
Shout out Louis Gomez.
Yeah. Um, right now we're, uh,
we want to say hello to all the hyena fans who have been listening and who have
been making more hyenas, spreading the word.
We also want to say hello to whatever internet blogger may be tuning in right
now after me and Chrissy got hired for something. Yes. Hi. How are you?
How's your day. We know you're sitting there in your little apartment. Okay.
You got three roommates right now and you're definitely eating Sabra hummus with
carrots as you're perusing these, um, podcasts for slurs.
Now.
Save you a little time. You're not going to have to search too far.
Just keep listening to this podcast because they are a come man. Yeah,
they're coming. And it's just, it doesn't change. I think it's inevitable. It's,
it's just, what's going to happen. Okay. So yeah. Listen,
here's the truth to the situation. Okay. I,
if you guys don't know Shane Gillis, friend of the show, great comedian,
happy to see him get SNL. Thank, uh, you know, he's a really funny kid.
He said some, uh,
slurs about Asians on a podcast two years ago. Some FF, Seth Simon,
I believe his name was, there was a few of them. Yeah. These kids,
they dug through the, the, they dug through the trash to find the stuff.
It's whatever. Yeah. You can't say those words,
but it's also like it's a podcast. He's a comedian, whatever, whatever.
I don't think for a second, not for a second.
That Lorne Michaels and the people in SNL did not know that that was already out
hired the other first Asian higher bone yang also congrats him.
I've never met him, but heard good things about the kid who congrats to him,
that they didn't all know that this was going to happen and create a controversy
and a stir to get eyes and ears and get people writing about the upcoming season
of SNL. I think that the machine of SNL,
they know how to any press is good press.
So you can't convince me that they didn't already know this was out. Yeah.
Lauren's a screwed in kid. He's going to get in this kid who we hired,
Seth Simon. He probably hired this kid. And he's just an FF.
That's yelling about. But it's like,
he's probably getting money from the SNL machine.
Melissa [inaudible] she also got in trouble for.
Villas and Yardi. What did she say? She said something.
And she got in trouble when she got out. She's a Latino woman.
She's a Latina woman. It's like, yeah. What was it? Mike sensitive tweets.
Like racial jokes and tweets. Yeah, nothing. Trevor Noah had a few as well.
He's a black kid from South Africa.
Yeah. It's just, nobody cares. The bottom line is nobody. It's all.
It's all part of the story. Genuinely. Nobody cares.
Nothing's going to happen to Shane. He's not going to get booed.
He's very funny. So I would expect him to do exceptionally well on the show.
But the bottom line is, is the truth is nobody cares.
I was at the wicked monk yesterday in Bay Ridge talking to some,
I was talking to some girls some, and you're also.
Wicked. Monk is a place where a lot of scholars.
Frequent. I mean, it's like a real Harvard bar. It's a Harvard bar.
And I was talking to a couple of girls and they started talking about the Louis
CK thing. And their consensus opinion was if,
if a guy's jerking off on the phone, you hang up.
And if a guy's jerking off in front of you and you,
and he's not blocking the door,
then you roll out a window and you throw them out a window and you just leave.
Because most of it's all, it's all.
We're living in such as soon as all this stuff came out with Shane and this,
I was like, you know,
you guys are getting involved outside and started staring down Chinese because
it's like, Oh, tweet, thank you, Zach. Yeah. Tweet a few support shamans. Like,
yeah, I do support Shane. The Twitter. It's all. If you tweet something out,
it's all. It's like, you're just feeding this thing. That's not real. Yeah.
They also took it out of context.
And also it's obviously not really about the morality, because if it was,
and they would have had this story come out before he got hired for Chanel.
Like if you're a pro, first of all, if you're a professional, if you,
if you cover comedy professionally, you're, you're basically,
that's the open mic scene for journalists.
Yeah. You're a loser. You're an open mic.
Journalist. Okay. Um, but if you're covering comedy,
aren't you supposed to be doing field research?
Aren't you supposed to be writing these articles before? There's a big hire.
Why did you wait for him to get hired at SNL in order for this to come out?
And another thing is, listen, listen,
jokes exist in context, right? Okay.
Imagine context, good or bad jokes.
By the way, Mike's wiping off the laptop screen.
So you know what happened on that laptop screen early this morning,
late last night, when a kid has to wipe it off,
he shot some of his glue on from there.
And the kid was gluing on the laptop screen. What it is, what it is. Yeah.
He got some Slack, whatever you say,
is that what you call your toothpaste these days? Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Cause your Turkey would have Slurpee.
Turkey would have Slurpee. Turkey would have slept together for my fitness fans.
It's do some burpees getting sloppy or your burpee would have slept.
We would love to have some of our plus size fans send us turkeys would have
slurp. It just dude Turkey would have slept. Show us your fat gobbled.
Chin would have slept. Chris. We're just New York kids were just funny.
We're just funny, screwed in kids. And I got to pee again. I haven't STD. Yeah.
And I did the impossible burger. Yannis may go D cut. I may go down.
I'm a little lightheaded, made an Apple.
You may have to move your seat behind Yani.
You may have to lay down and be the nets because I know you had a few of those
cupcakes at Sergio's birthday party. It's what it is, what it is. And I like to,
the vacate was a snowballs and ring bakes. Yeah. It wasn't truly,
that's hilarious. Did he do any cocaine in his own bathroom?
Not that he let us know, but were there any pieces?
Cause Puerto Ricans have pieces in their family with a couple of pieces. Uh,
none of that were there. Did you on anybody? Yeah.
But not on purpose. I love Mike emoji. Yeah. Yeah.
He's a good kid. And he gets it unlike.
Does it get it Zack?
Yeah. So jokes exist in context. Good or bad jokes. Right?
That's where they live. In context.
You can consider contexts like water and jokes are like fish. Right? Okay.
Keep the fish in the water. Right. You can't take a joke out of context.
You ever like talk to somebody and they try to tell you something funny that
someone else said, and then it doesn't work and they go, ah,
you had to be there. Yeah. You had to be there basically means
the jokes out of context. You weren't there.
That's what a professional comedian is. Jokes exist in context on the podcast.
In that moment, when you try to retell it, it's not a joke anymore.
It's a statement. So just leave comedians alone. You're an open mic.
Journalist, stay the away. I understand you've created a job for yourself.
Cause all the important jobs are taken right in about important stuff.
But we are just clowns and you are acting like the snitch
in the front of the class. Do you understand? You're not going to stop us.
The people don't care.
There's enough for you because there's not a lot of real jobs out there and you
don't want to work a real job. So there's enough for you to retweet and like,
and comment on each other's posts.
And that's why you think there's a scene out there that cares about this.
No body.
Yeah. Nobody cares. This is America.
People can say what they want.
And the heartbeat of a free nation is uncensored comedy.
Do you know what I'm playing right now? What are you playing?
The German national ant. That's not what I thought it was. Yeah. Cause,
cause you're saying you're making some German points right now. No, I'm not.
You just kamikaze. If you would a German national Anthem, I don't want it.
I wanted you to play the stars and stripes charming.